[موسيقى]
اسمع كنا بنعرف انه هو طبعا سن البلوك هو
السن الاساسي للحدا لاي شخص يبلش الصيام
بس احنا طبعا لازم نبلش نقرب الطفل
تدريجيا على هذا
الموضوع لعمر المناسب اللي هو ما بين سبع
سنوات وعشر سنوات تعتمد على الحاله الصحيه
لطفل وعلى عامل الادراك عنده لهذا الموضوع
اهم شيء لما بده يبلش نبلش نحن نصومه فتره
كتير صغيره اللي هي ممكن تكون من صلاه
العصر لصلاه المغرب واهم شيء لما بيجي
يفطر يكون في تحفيز بحيث انه نحن نخصص له
مكان على الطاوله ونحاول نحضر له الاكلات
اللي هو بحبها مشان يحس انه هو عمل شيء
كثير كبير واهم شيء وجبه الفطور لانه وجبه
الفطور هي الوجبه الاساسيه بعامل نمو
الطفل واهم شيء وقت السحور الاكل متنوع
صحي وقليل الملوحه مشان ما يحس بالعطش
[موسيقى]